اعربت وكاله الاستخبارات المركزيه
الامريكيه سي اي اي عن مخاوفها من قيام
شراكه دفاعيه كامله بين روسيا وايران
واعتبرتها تهديدا لجيران ايران وخصوصا
اسرائيل وقال وليمبرت مدير الوكاله ان لدى
بلاده مخاوف من امكانيه تقديم موسكو دعما
انتقاليا وعسكريا لطهران في مقابل تزويد
ايران لروسيا بطائرات مسيره في حربها على
اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان هناك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما مدى دقه التقديرات
الامريكيه بشان تاسيسي شراكه دفاعيه كامله
بين روسيا وايران وما الذي تخشاه واشنطن
من قيامه تلك الشراكه وما هي الدول التي
تقع في دائره تهديد الشراكه الدفاعيه
الروسيه الايرانيه وفق الاستخبارات
الامريكيه وما مخزن الاشاره الى اسرائيل
على وجه التحديد في هذا الصدد وما امكانيه
مضيئه التعاون بين موسكو والظهران الى
شراكه دفاعيه كامله وعلى اي نحو يمكن ان
تنعكس على جيران ايران وما هي خياراتهم في
مواجهتها
[موسيقى]
في مناسبه ليست الاولى خلال الاشهر
القليله الماضيه اعربت الولايات المتحده
عن مخاوفها مما سمته تاسيس شراكه دفاعيه
كامله بين روسيا وايران واعتبرتها تهديدا
لاسرائيل فقد قال ويليامبرز مدير وكاله
الاستخبارات المركزيه الامريكيه سي اي اي
لوسائل الاعلام مؤخرا ان لدى واشنطن مخاوف
من امكانيه البحث موسكو سبل تقديم دعم
انتقاليا وعسكريا لطهران في المقابل في
مقابل
الروسي في الحرب على اوكرانيا
انا مثل هذا التطور يشكل تهديدا حقيقيا
للدول المجاوره لايران بحسب قوله من دون
اغفال ذكر اسرائيل على وجه التحديد في هذا
الصدد
[موسيقى]
مناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من واشنطن
الدكتور خليل العناني استاذ العلوم
السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه والباحث
بالمركز العربي في واشنطن ومعنى من الدوحه
الدكتوره فاطمه الصمادي الباحثه الاولى في
مركز الجزيره للدراسات والخبيره في الشان
الايراني مرحبا
سنبدا معك هذه بدايه شراكه دفاعيه عميقه
بين ايران وروسيا كما يقول ويليامبرز مدير
الى اي مدى يعكس ذلك الواقع
شراكه بشكل كامل هذه مساله ما زالت بعيده
عن قائمه العلاقات الايرانيه الروسيه ما
يحدث هو تحول في شكل ومستوى العلاقه هذا
صحيح لكن شراكه استراتيجيه شامله او كامله
هذا يعني تحالف استراتيجي العلاقه بين
طهران وموسكو لم تصل الى التحالف
الاستراتيجي لكنها ايضا
انتقلت من مرحله الشراكه الاستراتيجيه دون
ان تصل الى التحالف الاستراتيجي هناك تحول
كبير في العلاقه
كبير جدا من وجهه نظري تحالف استراتيجي له
مقتضيات كثيره يحول دونها طبيعه العلاقات
الايرانيه الروسيه الجانب التاريخي منها
مستوى السابق من العلاقه ما زالت ايضا
هناك خطوات كثيره تحتاج ان بعد لتصل الى
التحالف الاستراتيجيه لا روسيا ولا ايران
تستطيع ان تقدم على تحالف استراتيجي بهذه
همم السرعه لكن بالتاكيد التحول قد حدث في
طبيعه العلاقه بين ايران وروسيا وهذا
التحول بدا منذ القضيه السوريه يعني منذ
ان دخلت روسيا الى الساحه السوريه
والعلاقات الايرانيه الروسيه تشهد تحولا
كبيرا المساله المهمه من وجهه نظره هي
تتعلق بالفكر السياسي لبوتين وقائد الثوره
الاسلاميه علي الخامنئي لديهما فكر سياسي
مشترك يتعلق بضروره اجراء تغيير في النظام
العالمي وطريقه اداره العالم وهذا همم
واضح من همم
اجتماعاتهما
والتحول الكبير حدث فعلا بعد الزياره
الاخيره لبوتين واجتماعه مع ايه الله عليه
المساله
مع ايضا ان هذا التعاون الاستراتيجي او
الشراكه الاستراتيجيه همم من الممكن ان
تقدم لايران همم بعض القضايا التي تحتاجها
بشكل خفيف من ذلك المنظومه الدفاعيه
منظومه الدفاعيه متطوره تكون قادره على
الصد اي هجوم في المستقبل على ايران وهذا
مطروح في العلاقات حاليا المساله اخرى همم
واختم بها ربما لننتقل الى مساله اخرى
تتعلق بتطوير المنظومه الجويه الايرانيه
وهذه مساله في غايه الاهميه لايران تزويد
ايران بطائرات سوخوي المساله مهمه جدا
دكتور خليل العناني ما الذي تخشاه
الولايات المتحده من هذا التقارب
انا اعتقد هناك عده امور الامر الاول
متعلق اولا اي نوع من الشراك الاستراتيجيه
وانا فاي الشخص ده تحالف 30 فقط لانه
بنتكلم عن حاله تعاون وحاله يعني اتفاق
يعني على سبيل المثال قبل حوالي عام من
الان وقعت وقع البلدين روسيا وايران
اتفاقيه لمده 20 عام بين البلدين تتعلق
بامور اقتصاديه وعسكريه واستراتيجيه
وامنيه لذلك وبالتالي نحن ازاء تحول من
شركه استراتيجيه الى تحالف استراتيجي
امليته الظروف الدوليه والاقليميه فاولا
جزء متعلق بخوف امريكا ولا متعلق بفك
العذر نعلم جميعا انه واشنط يحاول على 40
عام فرض عزله دوليه على ايران ونجحت بشكل
او باخر في ذلك الاطار الامر الثاني هيقدر
فك العزله على الروسي نعلم الجميع ان هناك
عقوبات الدوليه خاصه امريكيه هناك حرب
طحين الان في اوكرانيا همم نتيجه للصراع
بين روسيا بين اوكرانيا هناك دعم امريكي
غير مسبوق الاوكرانيا وبالتالي اي خروج
روسي محاوله انشاء تحالفات استراتيجيه مع
الدول الخارجيه خاصه مثل ايران يمثل نوع
من تهديد او مخاوف امريكيه لانه يع ضرب
للحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا الحاجه الثالثه
متعلقه بمخوف امريكيه من احتمال ان تمثل
هذه الشركه الاستراتيجيه وتحالف يسترجي
بين موسى وبين طهران تهديد لحلفاء امريكا
في المنطقه همم خاصه اسرائيل ودول عربيه
اخرى وبالتالي اي تقارب استراتيجي بين
طهران ومسكو يمثل تهديد بشكل او باخر او
على الاقل مخاوف امريكيه كما جاي على
الانسان الدكتور خليل السؤال هنا يعني الم
تكن الولايات المتحده تتوقع ان يحدث هذا
التقارب عندما ضغطت بشكل كبير على روسيا
لعزلها كان هناك توقع بان يتم توقيع
الاتفاق النووي مع ايران العكس حصل تدهور
هذا الملف همم وعادت همم العقوبات
الامريكيه على ايران الم يؤخذ هذا التقارب
بين البلدين بعين الاعتبار
كلام صحيح ال سي بالفعل الذي دفع هذا
التحالف هذا الشكل الخارجيه الى الامام هو
الموقف الامريكي سواء من روسيا او من
ايران على سبيل المثال كما تفضلت وقلت
تهدئه وتجميد الملف النووي الايراني دفع
بشكل او باخر يتقويه علاقات بين روسيا بين
طهران نعلم جميع انه هذا ملف متوقف منذ
حوالي 7 ثمان شهور حتى الان
التفاوض ليس هناك اي نوع من التواصل بين
الطرفين خاصه في مواد فينا في نفس الوقت
كما قلت قبل قليل الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه دفعت بامريكا الى ان تصبح شريك
كبير جدا في هذه الحرب وبالتالي فرض عزل
على روسيا بشكل اخر لوجود خلفها خارجين
ذلك على سبيل المثال في محاوله تقويه
الشراكه ما بين الصين وروسيا ما بين طهران
الان وروسيا بين روسيا وبالتالي امريكا
مسئوله بشكل اوخر عن هذا التقارب الان
وبالتالي ليس هناك امكانيه ان تنوب الى
نفسها في هذا الاطار طيب همم
لماذا تنفي ايران باستمرار همم هذا
التقارب الذي نتحدث عن سواء كانت تحالف او
هناك همم او يعني همم مهما مهما كان اسمه
اا في ايطار يندرج لماذا تحاول ان تقول
ايران انه لا علاقه لها بتزويد روسيا بهذه
الاسلحه لاسيه مع المسيرات وتقول ان هذا
حدث قبل الحرب على اوكرانيا
يعطي
النظام وتدرك ان هذه المساله قد تجر
على همم كثير من ال- ال-
القضايا خاصه همم يعني يضعها مباشره في
مواجهه الغرباء ويصنفها على انها همم جزء
من المعركه او همم قد دخلت المعركه الى
جانب روسيا وهذا
نعم ما زالت تريد ان همم ان لا تصنف بانها
لا تريد التفاوض بشان ملفها النووي
المساله الاخرى ان هناك نخبه سياسيه
ايرانيه لا يستهان بها تعتقد ان من اجهض
التوصل الى اتفاق مع بشان ال همم الملف
النووي الايراني هو العامل الروسي او
التدخل همم الروسي وهناك ايضا من يقول
بانه لولا اندلاع الحرب في اوكرانيا كانت
سيتم التوصل همم الى همم اتفاق بشان
البرنامج النووي الايراني العقوبات التي
دعت الطبيعه الدوليه على ايران مهما مستوى
العلاقه مع روسيا ايران اليوم او غدا
تحتاج الى ان تنهي هذه همم العقوبات لان
الشراكه الاقتصاديه مع روسيا الغير كافيه
لاخراج ايران من ازمتها الاقتصاديه وهذه
مساله تدركها ايران جيدا المساله الاخرى
ال- ال- الحديث عن دور ايران وموضوع
المسيارات ايران تدرك ان همم في ذلك ربما
اذا كانت المساله حقيقيه فهذا تصنيف
لايران بانها اصبحت جزءا من المعركه
وسيكون لذلك تبيعاته واذا كان هناك نوع من
المبالغه في ذلك فهذا ايضا نوع من همم
صناعه حاله اللي همم ربما معاقبه ايران
اكثر او ربما توجيه ضربه عسكريه لايران
دكتور خليل عندما كشف ان روسيا تستعين
بالمسيرات الايرانيه في الحرب على
اوكرانيا في الولايات المتحده جرى التدليل
على ذلك بان الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه لعزل
لروسيا نجحت وبالتالي هي تلجا الان الى
ايران وكوريا الشماليه ولكن الان نسمع لغه
مختلفه نسمع لغه الخوف من هذا التقارب
ماذا نفهم من جول ذلك
انه امريكا حسابات خاطئه في هذا الاطار
امريكا عندما قامت بمد اوكرانيا بكل انواع
الاسلحه سواء دفاعيه او غير دفاعيه كانت
تعتقد بانه من هناك امكانيه ان تنتصر
اوكرانيا في هذه الحرب على الاقل تقوم
باستنزاف روسيا بشكل اخر لقى احدث الفارق
في هذه الحرب كما نعلم جميع ال سي هو
المسيرات الايرانيه التي تقوم الان
استخدامها روسيا تستخدم على السلمان مثلا
اهم طياره ايرانيه شاهد 36 يصل المداح
حوالي 2500 كيلو متر بعد انسحاب روسيا من
فيينا عفوا منك كيف ذهابها بشكل اباخر في
اتجاه الشرق كان هناك بنتكلم منه سيارات
بشكل او باخر وبالتالي امريكا كانت تعتقد
بانه امكانيه روسيا ان تتراجع ان تترك
الساحه الالكترونيه لكن الان هناك استخدام
له سيارات ايرانيه وقد اعترف بذلك وزير
الخارجيه الايراني قبل فتره عندما تحدث عن
بالفعل هناك تحالف ما بين هناك نوع من
الشراكه في اعطاء مسيرات لموسكو وكان هناك
يعتبر تصريح لحد بعيد اول مره يتم
الاعتراف بذلك هناك قناه امريكيه بانه
الذي احدث الفرق الحرب القرنيه على روسيا
خلال اخر ثلاث شهور هو هذه المستويات
الايرانيه وبالتالي هناك مخفف امريكيه
متوهده من هذا الاطار واعتقد انه فتره
المقبله قد نشهد نوع من الضغط في هذا
الاطار سواء من خلال يعني اعاده حلقات ملف
النووي الايراني من اجل الجاز بايران نوعا
ما بعيدا عن موسكو بالتالي محاوله دق اسفل
بين الطرفين طيب ويليامبرز في اطار حديثه
دكتور خليل عن همم المخاوف الامريكيه من
هذه الشراكه همم يقول ان انعكاسها الاكبر
لن يكون في الميدان الاوكراني ربما بلف
الشرق الاوسط كيف همم لو فصلنا في هذا
الموقف
انا اعتقد عده امور ذا ال سي اول امر
متعلق بامكانيه ان تحصل ايران على منظومه
الدفاع الصاروخي اس 400 وهذا يعتبر تحول
نوعي قد يقلب قد يقلب موازين الاسترديه في
الشرق الاوسط نعلم جميعا انه هناك يعني
ممانعه امريكيه لان تحصل اي دوله اقساطيه
على هذه المنظومه الصاروخيه تعتبر تحول
استراتيجي ده الامر الاول الامر الثاني
هذا بيعني تحول ايضا وضع ايران في المنطقه
باتجاه ان تصبح دوله مؤثره لحد بعيد لانه
عندما تصبح لدي هذه الانظمه الصاروخان
المتقدمه تعني ان ليس هناك مشكله في ان
تذهب في اتجاه تعديل قوتها في المنطقه من
خلال الخلفاء في المنطقه العربيه الامر
اخر متعلق باسرائيل هتعتبر تحدي كبير جدا
بالنسبه لامريكا كيف يمكن لامريكا تسمح او
ان همم يعني تستمر في ما يطلق عليه همم
القوه الاسرائيليه النوعيه على حساب
المنطقه العربيه بشكل الاوسط وبالتالي
هناك ثقافه امريكيه جاده في ان تصبح ايران
قوه اقليميه مؤثره من خلال دعم روسي عسكري
طبعا بالاضافه المخاوي موجوده بين الطرفين
نتيجه لاتهامات امريكيه وغربيه لرانسيعيه
لامتلك سلاحف النووي ونعلم جميعا ايضا ان
هناك بالفعل حرب خفيه بين تل ابيب بين
طهران بين ذلك من خلال استهداف لعلماء
سواء علماء صواريخ باليستيه ايرانيين او
علماء في النقود نعم هل تستطيع اسرائيل ان
ااا تدخل همم
تقلب همم هذا التحالف لتضع حد له خصوصا في
ضوء المواقف التي عبر عنها وزير الخارجيه
الاسرائيلي الجديد همم
القريبه الى حد ما من موسكو واتصاله
بالامس بوزير الخارجيه الروسي همم اسرائيل
تتحيه يعني الفرصه لتجد ذريعه لتوجيه ضربه
عسكريه قويه للبرنامج النووي الايراني على
وجه التحديد لكن اسرائيل لا تستطيع ان
تقوم بخطوه من هذا النوع منفرده هي تحتاج
الى غطاء
امريكي واضح ومع بهذا همم الخصوص في ظني
ان ال- ال-
اتبعات عمل همم او خطوه اسرائيليه هي
تبعات كبيره جدا تعيق همم هذه المساله
بمعنى ان قوه الردع الايرانيه على هذا
الصعيد خاصه مع اا دخول ايران في ساحه ال
انها دوله مصنعه للمسيرات التي اثبتت
فعاليتها وايضا همم مجموعه من العوامل
الاخرى تجعل هذه المهمه عسيره جدا بالنسبه
همم لاسرائيل لذلك انا في ظني انا المساله
ستبقى في اطار حرب الظل لكن قد نشهد تصاعد
في مستوى حرب الظل بين ايران واسرائيل
الدكتور خليل كيف قيمت التعامل الاسرائيلي
همم في ضوء هذه المخاوف التي تعبر عنها
الولايات المتحده من التقارب بين طهران
وموسكو حديث وزير الخارجيه الاسرائيلي على
انه في المرحله المقبله
يتم التقليل من الحديث عن اوكرانيا
واتصاله بالامس بنظيره الروسي
هذا صحيح عندما نقرا تصريحات الكوهين وزير
الخارجيه السوريه الجديد نرى انه يحاول
تربيه المخاوف الروسيه خاصه في ظل توقف
علاقات بين الطرفين نتيجه اولا للموقف
الاسرائيلي الداعم بشكل ابو اخر لاوكرانيا
همم في نفس الوقت الموقف من مساله الوكاله
اليهوديه وعوده او سفر اليهود تهجير
اليهود الروس الى اسرائيل وبالتالي هناك
نوع من التوتر في الحكومه السابقه نحن
الان ايذاء محاوله من اسرائيل لتهديدات
الروسيه وفي نفس الوقت محاوله غاز بروسيا
بعيد عن ايران بشكل او باخر همم هذه ما
خوف ما خوف بالنسبه خوف مهمه جدا اي تقارب
استراتيجي يبين همم موسكو طهران يمثل تحدي
بالنسبه لاسرائيل اكثر من جهه الجهه
الاولى متعلقه بتقويه البعد العسكري عند
ايران كما قلت قبل قليل نحن وزاء حرب
الدكتوره فاطمه حرب الظل مستمر على مدار
سنوات سابقا نتكلم على همم تقويه العلاقات
ما بين روسيا بين مصر و قد يمثل نوعا ما
فكر العزله الدوليه عن طهران بنتكلم على
ايضا امكانيه استخدام او الاستفاده من قبل
طهران لم لما يتعلق بالملف النووي
الايراني وبالتالي هناك ملفات كثيره جدا
معقده تحاول اسرائيل ان تجتذب بروسي بعيدا
عن ايران في هذا الاطار لكن دكتوره فاضي
ما يعني في هذا الاطار محاوله جذب محاولات
اسرائيل لجذب روسيا بعيدا عن ايران هل هي
سهله باعتقادك وهل هناك خشيه ايرانيه من
امكانيه ان تحدث
الايرانيه قائمه همم مثلا على سبيل المثال
في الساحه السوريه الكثير من الضربات
الاسرائيليه
همم للايرانيين في سوريا تتم همم تحت سمع
الروسي وبصلهم بل همم ايضا سابقا قدمت
روسيا نوع من الضمانات بان الانتشار
الايراني في سوريا لن يكون تهديدا
لاسرائيل لذلك انا همم عندما قلت انه ما
زالت المسافه بعيده عن همم الشراكه
الاستراتيجيه الشامل او التحالف
الاستراتيجي فذلك لانه هناك معطيات على
ارض الواقع همم تدعم همم تدعم ذلك ايضا
ااه روسيا توزن همم مساله العلاقه مع
اسرائيل بالنسبه لعلاقتها مع ايران همم
لذلك هذا هي نوع من همم موازنه المصالح لا
يمكن ان تتخلى روسيا عن همم كثير من
مصالحها فقط لانها دخلت في هذه الشراكه مع
مع ايران انا في ظني انها شراكه انتقائي
في ملفات بعينها دكتور خليل همم ويليامبرز
يتحدث عن ان هذا التحالف او هذه الشراكه
الدفاعيه تشكل تهديدا لاسرائيل ولي جيران
ايران ايضا من المعنى بهذا الحديث
ولا اسرائيل بلا شك لنقوم كما كنا قبل
قليل اي تحالف استراتيجي او اشتراك
استراتيجيه بين ايران
وبين بوسكو يمثل تحول نوعي في موازين وقوف
الشرق الاوسط وبالتالي هذا لا يصوم في
مساحه اسرائيل الامر الثاني متعلق بالخلل
في الخليج العربي نعلم جميع ان هناك ما
خوف ايرانيه عفوا النقاوه في السعوديه
واماراتيه وخليجيه من من ايران وبالتالي
هناك سعي امريكي لتهدئه هذه المخاوف
وقرانا وسمعنا قبل حوالي شهرين من الان
تهديدات ايرانيه بامكانيه استهداف
السعوديه خاصه في ظل التوتر الداخلي في
ايران وكان هناك نوع من التواصل
لاستخبارات بين امريكا وبين السعوديه في
هذا الاطار وبالتالي هناك موقف امريكيه
جده لن يؤدي التحالف او الشكل اتجاه بين
طهران وبين موسكو الى نوع من خلل التوازن
في منطقه الخليج العربي بما يهدد مصالح
امريكا من جهه اولا ثم يهدد مصالح الخلفاء
من جهه اخرى ما رايك يا دكتوره فاطمه
نعم هو لا المساله مرتبطه بمجموعه من
الامور من ضمنها العوده الى مساله التفاوض
ان تنجح مساله التفاوض في احياء الاتفاق
النووي اذا حدث ذلك فهذا سيكون له
التاثيرات كبيره حتى على مستوى العلاقه مع
روسيا لكن اذا فشلت العمليه التفاضيه
بمعنى انها وصلت الى نهايه معلنه واقيلا
ان تم اعلان وفاه الاتفاق النووي بشكل
كامل وفشل العمليه التفاضيه فانا في ظني
انا الاستراتيجيه الايرانيه في المنطقه
ستتبدل بمعنى ان ما كانت ايران تسمي
بالصبر الاستراتيجي همم ايضا يعلن نهايه
هذه المرحله مرحله ستكون همم ربما قاسيه
على دول المنطقه شكرا جزيلا لكما من
الدوحه الدكتوره فاطمه الباحثه الاولى في
مركز الجزيره للدراسات والخبيره الايراني
وشكرا للدكتور خليل العناني استاذ العلوم
السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه والباحث
بالمركز العربي في واشنطن ضيفنا من
العاصمه الامريكيه
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر شكرا لمتابعتكم مشاهدينا
الكرام الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]